[Music]
this show was magical scarier than I
maybe anticipated going into it were you
guys familiar with the comics before you
started on this not really yeah not so
much I came to the show and had not
actually read the comics I knew about
them and I had done some research online
yeah when I had my meeting but when I
met the showrunners they said your
characters so interpreted differently or
approached differently than the comics
so here they are enjoy them but it's not
a literal translation so what I ended up
doing was reading getting into them very
gently and not until nina reaches the
breaking point
yeah and becomes very much like you know
the drunken and sad then I really dived
into the comics then and just and just
immerse myself there
let's break down that finale is there
hope for Elly are we meant to believe
that she's stuck behind the Omega door
or yeah I mean I don't know what happens
to someone when they get thrown into
like yeah but nothing good has come out
of there so I can't imagine that you I
mean first of all these characters are
not gonna want to open that door for any
reason ever again laughs oh I don't feel
why are you so hard characters yeah yeah
all right
shapeshifter dodge is actually gay yes
so when you guys thought it was Lucas
was really yeah that was gonna be
anybody a lot to process what did you
guys make of that and how do you think
that will affect season two I mean you
know you get so used to this this
villain seeming a certain way yeah and
this energy and you and and then you
another hand you got you come to love
these characters including Gabe and Gabe
ingratiate himself into all of our lives
and especially Ken disease and the
braggers pull up under us at the end of
the season obviously and going forward I
mean it's gonna be a very different sort
of what I like about it is it really
preys on the weakness of the family
members like evil and its smartest form
is disguised and hidden and so if this
dodge character has turned into Gabe
which has won Lindsey's you know
affection and she may not have oh yeah
she chose up just like it's like so ya
know so it's like you know first dodge
pray it on you know Bodie you know in
season one legal is very much like yeah
I mean from without sure know that we're
being almost like invaded or being
attacked by this unknown enforcement it
gets much more horror that's gonna be
coming from yeah do you think it's safe
to say that Kinzie
in the most danger in season two yeah
because of that connection to Gabe me
being like I hope so like i hope 'tyler
Camellia gets like dragged across
I mean honestly nobody knows who gave us
so they're all they're all subject yeah
to danger I mean I do feel like
throughout this season it's sort of a
recurring theme the Kinsey is the most
reckless yeah sure yeah she jumps into
things of course she get out of her yeah
so yeah what do you expect
did she have to put it back no I know
Eden does get hit with agloe yeah bullet
so how do you think that will affect
season two well it's like I mean the
Army's growing bigger that's how it
feels that's a good way to put it really
honestly you kind of raise me up
stranger things like when they moles up
like when that was applied like that's
the first thing I thought it was you
know there's this it's like now there's
totally get along questions because in
this season it's you know dodge you know
right that's the demon dodged but
there's a whole world of demons out
there yeah and she's just one of many
and what new ones would be like sure and
it could just she have separate powers
or she you know so what do they want the
same thing yeah are they gonna get it
along so how you feeling
three hopes for season two that you guys
would like to see that we'd get a season
2 they told me love it
yeah they told me they're writing see
them to other they are writing so again
this isn't to that people love it we get
a season three oh there we go
I mean I hope that we get to work
together
yeah oh yes we talked about that we
didn't get a whole lot of like one
except prison kidnapping right yep asone
I've all I love the giant key from the
comics which is the one that turns you
it's like 40-foot tall yeah and I in the
comic because it's Tyler who turns into
a giant and like takes his his brother
and sister up on his hat can you imagine
that's the key you want Percy I do I
just want to be in a green room know we
get to go back to our normal lives what
is your message to fans of the comics do
you have I hope you like it I mean you
know it's funny because when you're you
obviously you know that that people love
these stories and you know people love
these character but there's a point when
you're working and you show up to work
every day and see your friends and you
have you know you have to go scene by
scene moment by moment and you sort of
forget about like you you have to you're
invested in what you're doing you almost
even forget that anyone else will ever
see it like yeah it feels like you know
it feels like you're playing around with
friends yeah you're establishing a world
and a connection with each other and
you're just making it as specific as
possible and we had a lot of fun today I
mean I hope that people I always hoped
that the fun that we have when we're
doing here plays you can see you can
feel it on the screen and I know that
people care about these characters like
I hope one thing we couldn't be luckier
about is Joe Hill and Gabriel Rodriguez
are so supportive of us in the way that
it was made and what they've seen they
came to that a couple of times to visit
us they just truly haven't been
wouldn't be more lovely or generous with
with us which I think for me it really
gave me a reassurance it made me feel
like okay I know like yeah do you really
want those guys to be I also hope I mean
I hope people who are very familiar with
the comment yeah watch and are surprised
because there are things in the show
that go differently than you yes that I
hope that people who feel like they they
have a step up on everyone else they
know every twist and turn yeah
[Music]